parce que je suis pas un menteur trop
d'animaux tout tuer tous les jours oui
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait un casting j'ai fait un
casting on m'a pas appelé en me donnant
le jack non non
j'ai fait des
[Musique]
screenser ou pas non pas du tout je
l'aurais pas fait c'était juste ouais
parce que ils ont qu'à regarder tu vois
et pas que tu es fan de Madonna aussi je
suis le plus grand fan dans Star
je veux dire j'ai vu quasiment tous les
derniers concerts de la Madone mais je
l'ai pas rencontré personnellement j'ai
eu l'occasion et j'ai refusé parce que
justement j'ai peur on m'a toujours dit
de départ rencontrer
regardez on a fait une petite compil là
[Musique]
vous avez quand même largement dominé
les autres coachs etc est-ce que vous
avez parfois senti des petites jalousies
de vos collègues
[Rires]
non non
jalousie je pense que en fait c'est oui
non non le mot non jalousie non parce
que déjà on est tous très différents
pour être très honnête et je vais être
vraiment honnête je pense qu'il y avait
même pas essayer de faire une petite
compétition avec moi j'étais déjà trop
loin dès le départ et trop sûr de moi
donc je pense qu'ils sont calmés dès le
départ
toi tu as même dansé dans un clip de
Céline Dion oui ah ouais tu étais dans
le costume de Deadpool regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mariah Carey
non mais Mariah Carey alors elle est
sympa
j'ai vraiment ouais je suis fan depuis
toujours donc ça c'est un des jobs quand
on m'a annoncé ça qu'elle était
intéressé pour que je la cote j'y
croyais pas du tout ça commence à
arriver Mariah Carey elle veut que tu la
côte c'était pas de la danse c'était
vraiment du coaching justement apprendre
à marcher à prendre la positionner en
talon elle va elle redémarrer une
tournée donc je l'ai un petit peu
coacher sur des positions de corps on
appelle ça movement coach vous pourriez
coacher Siri par exemple sur des
mouvements
[Musique]
merci d'être là vous avez regardé
l'émission hier non malheureusement
journal intime d'une vie à lutter contre
les kilos
en fait
j'ai deux enfants je suis quelqu'un de
très gourmande toute façon qui n'aime
pas manger on va dire c'est un plaisir
donc après il y a des choses qui peuvent
nous aider comme des compléments
alimentaires des coups de fin moi
beaucoup aidé pour diminuer mais mes
assiettes par deux faire beaucoup de
sport comme on dit l'alimentation c'est
60% le sport ça aide aussi beaucoup des
compléments alimentaires c'est là c'est
fait pour nous aider mais faire
attention aux compléments alimentaires
il y en a qui peuvent vous détruire la
santé qui sont pas bons il y en a qui
sont bien donc faire attention parce que
vous êtes fait embrouiller sur des
régimes
pas forcément c'est pour moi en fait
faire un régime il y en a qui vont le
faire parce qu'ils doivent faire deux
trois kilos donc le faire en une semaine
deux semaines perdre vite oui mais quand
on a 10 kilos à perdre il faut prendre
son temps pour le faire mais il faut
aussi rappeler aux jeunes rappeler aux
gens et c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit mon
livre il y a des filtres il y a des
retouches photos il faut pas croire tout
ce qu'on voit c'est pour ça que moi je
n'utilise aucun filtre que j'essaye
vraiment de faire voir les choses après
par exemple là on vient de me
diagnostiquer un lipoodème c'est-à-dire
que je fais du sport tous les jours je
fais attention à ce que je mange j'ai
perdu 25 kg mais j'aurais toujours des
gens de poteau c'est une maladie en fait
que une femme sur dix a qui est peu
connu en France qui est très connu en
Allemagne et en Espagne et du coup en
fait ça commence à se développer mais je
pourrais faire du sport à vie et en fait
ça ne partira pas bah on peut se rendre
malade c'est vraiment une maladie c'est
vraiment un combat qu'on peut mener et
peut des fois à perte parce qu'en fait
tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux mais
des fois il y a des gens ils peuvent pas
perdre ma mère donc c'est opéré elle
regrette en fait elle a fait un bypass
elle regrette parce qu'elle peut plus
manger de riz de pâtes elles sont
vraiment malade la réduction de la
réduction de l'estomac
il y en a plein qui en pleurent qui
pleure maintenant et pourtant c'est un
acte chirurgical il faut bien lire bien
réfléchir c'est lui alors quel est votre
conseil pour toutes les personnes qui
font le yoyo bah pour toutes les
personnes qui font le yoyo déjà se
renseigner pour voir si elles ont pas
des problèmes quand j'ai dit tout à
l'heure de lipo les podème de thyroïde
faire vraiment attention il y a les tout
doucement il vaut mieux mettre un an
pour perdre 10 kilos plutôt que de
mettre trois mois pour perdre 10 kilos
du coup provoquer des problèmes dans sa
santé faire attention à ce qu'on mange
parce que par exemple moi à l'époque on
m'avait dit des sushis c'est pas grave
bah c'est faux c'est super gras faire
attention comme on dit on a une pizza
que si sushis mais des fois on a un
nombre de calories à manger par jour je
te le dis une pizza c'est équivaut à 6
sushi
c'est la quantité il faut faire
attention à ce que tu manges c'est un
nom de calories par jour qu'on te prête
tu donnes des conseils toi tu vas te
donner des conseils de nutrition
trois hommes ont saccagé leur maison et
ont même volé la voiture de Jonathan
la procédure était en particulièrement
longue Jonathan a décidé d'aller
lui-même récupérer sa voiture
[Musique]
cambrioler un candidat de téléréalité
réalise lui-même l'enquête et retrouve
sa voiture il s'exprime ce soir dans
TPMP on a tout de suite été au
commissariat enfin j'ai été au
commissariat j'ai déposé ma chérie et
mon fils à l'abri ben quand je porte
plainte je sors du commissariat pour
être très franche je suis assez déçu je
me rends compte que ça va être très
compliqué que les choses vont prendre
beaucoup trop de temps mais je me dis
les choses vont pas bouger donc je
décide de partir à la recherche du
véhicule volé et je me rappelle que les
ordinateurs et téléphones ont été
retrouvés dans une poubelle en bas d'une
cité là où on vit à proximité de là où
on vit donc je décide de partir et je
tourne avec ma voiture
sans vraiment être certaines de ce que
j'allais trouver mais par chance et ben
je tombe dessus il y a des procédures
les policiers ils ont leur méthode trop
longue pour vous trop lentes mais c'est
leur manière de bosser et là vous vous
êtes pris pour un policier à la place de
la police moi ça me gêne les procédures
il y en a les prélevés les prélèvements
d'empreintes et d'ADN ça prend entre 6
et 8 mois pour avoir des retours la
voiture elle a le temps déjà de faire le
tour du monde ensuite contrairement à ce
que vous pensez les policiers bon pas
officiellement mais mon clairement dit
que parfois il vaut peut-être mieux
faire justice soi-même mais je me suis
pas arrêté là j'ai fait le tour de tout
le trajet j'ai récupéré les caméras de
surveillance de tout le voisinage et oui
en effet on continue je lâche pas la
faire on a des bonnes pistes et pour
être très franc ce qu'on parlait de la
police parce qu'il y a pas que des
connards dans la police
justement qui a été vraiment touché et
qui veut nous aider et qu'on fait de
manière informelle parce que justement
en passant par le canal formel et
classique ben ça prend une plante
l'enquête n'a même pas été attribué j'ai
même pas une nouvelle de l'enquêteur la
vérité c'est que je savais à quoi je
m'exposais je savais aussi qu'elle était
mes limites je sais que j'ai une famille
maintenant bien sûr je fais pas
n'importe quoi et quand je fais une
vidéo YouTube où j'explique ce qu'on
fait j'explique aussi que j'invite pas
les jeunes à faire la même chose par
exemple je mets les choses claire sur la
table et oui aujourd'hui j'ai
malheureusement pas le temps d'attendre
que les choses ne se fassent pas on dit
que lui c'est mis en danger et moi maire
de famille je préfère dire tu t'es mis
en danger et j'ai pas envie que mon fils
ou les enfants de ceux qui nous
regardent fassent la même chose que
Monsieur et qu'après ils disent ah mais
j'avais vu dans TPMP le garçon il a fait
ça moi mon fils il a fait mal et il
s'est pris une bastos donc je préfère
voilà c'est pour ça que je mais par
contre de de faire aussi réaliser que
aujourd'hui malheureusement quand il
nous arrive de se faire violer notre
intimité de se faire cambrioler parce
qu'il y en a la peine
les cambrioleurs je sais pas le terme
adéquat mais il se sentent en sécurité
et capable de tout parce qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'on va jamais les
attraper ça c'est la vérité
bon j'ai une petite question à vous
poser
journée d'expliquer et on le sent que
vous êtes un passionné
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas surtout
passionné de buzz beaucoup de gens vous
parlent de gens célèbre ou pas et est-ce
que vous ne cherchez pas désespérément
le buzz et est-ce que donc si tel est le
cas vous ne tapez pas sur les bouchers
pour faire vendre votre livre qui
d'ailleurs depuis votre passage ici
étant hausse exponentielle dès le début
d'accord est-ce que votre métier c'est
pas le boss je vous réponds est-ce que
je pourrais avec plaisir déjà déjà
Cyril je vous demande de pas me couper
la parole est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous avez
combien de temps
est-ce que vous y reviendra pas mon
livre sur la boucherie
est-ce que vous avez lu mon livre vous
savez pourquoi je n'ai pas lu
trop de base
de télé pendant deux ans c'est pas un
drame RTL oui j'ai essayé de m'en sortir
de cette merde de cette vie oui j'ai
retrouvé mon père mort sur la tombe de
mon frère ma grand-mère de cimetière
j'ai fait une méningite
j'en ai chié toute ma vie j'ai essayé de
me sortir de cette merde j'ai même
envoyé ma candidature à Monsieur Hanouna
pour devenir rubriqueur peut-être vous
l'avez jamais vu j'ai tout fait j'ai
tout fait mais par contre par contre
j'étais bouché enfin je gagne ma vie et
j'ai toujours caché mon métier je l'ai
caché mon métier elle mettait parce que
je voulais me sortir de cette merde je
suis végétarien je mange pas d'animaux
j'allais j'allais non mais je vous dirai
ce qui se passe aussi dans les abattoirs
mais attendez vous êtes en train de
décrépiller
pourquoi vous avez caché votre métier
d'être bouchée devant tous les Français
pourquoi parce que je suis pas un
menteur parce que les animaux sont tués
tous les jours
attendez il y a laissez-moi parler trop
d'animaux
d'accord c'est pas quelqu'un dit en
moyenne surface qui sont jetés à la
poubelle tant d'animaux tués pour rien
et vous me dites vous me reprochez rien
du tout excusez-moi parcours personnel
oui je suis un parcours personnel et je
le revendique voilà
ce que vous connaissez à quoi babe oui
Jeremstar l'accuse de diffamation il
avait accusé diffamation voilà sur notre
plateau à quoi elle souhaite nous donner
sa version des faits sur cette histoire
qui a fait énormément parler tu as
800000 followers sur insta ça marche
bien ça veut dire ouais toi tu comment
tu gagnes ta vie en fait ce que pour que
les gens comprennent alors moi je vais
être placement de produit comme tout le
monde avec des agences etc c'est un
indépendant donc c'est les prestataires
qui viennent eux-mêmes me contacter sur
WhatsApp et je réponds directement quoi
c'est moi qui fait le tri pour lui
parler d'une affaire ça concerne
Jeremstar a totalement tu as vu son
passage sur notre plateau et tu nous as
demandé un droit de réponse et ici je
vous dis on donne toujours les droits de
réponse et tous les droits de réponse
sont toujours les bienvenus quand j'ai
lancé le jeremstargate de base c'était
une cause noble j'ai jamais voulu créer
du buzz sur lui parce que bon gratter du
buzz sur Jeremstar surtout une fois tu
as fait ça alors de base c'est parti
d'un vol de scoop comment il a volé il a
sorti avant vous c'est ça non pas du
tout il est venu m'enregistrer la vidéo
sur snap donc tu son nom d'utilisateurs
un gros stylo en mettant source j'ai
rêvé star quoi donc de là moi j'avais
son numéro de téléphone je les joint je
lui ai dit c'est quoi cet article je
viens de voir ta sortie apparemment une
exclu sauf que je l'ai sorti avant toi
il m'a bloqué et c'est là que la guerre
a commencé j'ai été condamné apparemment
pour diffamation et également insultes
homophobe ça je le reconnais parce que
j'ai très mal avec ma bouche je le
reconnais vous regrettez bien sûr les
insultes n'avaient pas du tout
homophobe mais bien sûr sachant que
moi-même je suis homo l'intérêt un petit
peu voilà quoi mais concernant la
diffamation c'est totalement faux
sachant que moi mes preuves ont été
malheureusement pas reçu face à la
justice parce qu'ils vont clairement dit
c'est des enregistrements illégal à son
insu donc vous n'avez jamais été
condamné vous dites mais si j'ai dit ça
si j'étais condamné mais pour ça il
précise pas pourquoi j'ai été condamné
sur les mots et
quelqu'un pardon moi je fais une
différence quand même en note de
l'information et traiter quelqu'un de
pédophile son ami a bien été attendez
attendez mais c'est pas votre job
traiter quelqu'un de pédophile j'ai
aujourd'hui on est on est dans une
problématique il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes qui suicide justement à cause de
fausses rumeurs sur internet ou sur les
réseaux sociaux vous devriez être un
exemple vous avez une vingtaine d'années
je suis désolé c'est pas de
l'information c'est pas du journaliste
que d'aller balancer aveuglement sur
quelqu'un des choses terribles
un proche de Jeremstar sur nos Babybel
parce qu'il était avec belle des champs
à l'époque
il relayent sur les réseaux des
témoignages accusant ce quinquagénaire
d'avoir proposé de manière insistante
des rapports sexuels à d'autres hommes
pour certains mineurs donc ça n'a rien à
voir c'est ça l'histoire c'est
exactement ça voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]